for people who are first-time managers
I'm wondering whether you have advice
for them on how you've gone from being
an independent uh contributor you've
been on your own you've been climbing
the ranks maybe now you've been moving
into management how do you think about
or maybe how have you trained what have
you told managers over the years about
how to be great at what they want to do
well there's so many things you know a
lot of them are in the book but um uh
first of all to
understand and work with others who who
are working with you
for them to understand
how people are different
okay we're we're born differently we're
outwired differently we have different
preferences and so on uh for each
individual there's a certain nature and
then they develop over a period of time
to know what those pulls are for and to
work and to be truthful around that to
not let the
um ego barrier stand in the way of
getting into uh and stay in the way of
people knowing what they're like and the
truths of that so you um my own view is
uh you have to
understand each other you have to get a
truth you have to know what your
strengths and weaknesses are you have to
deal with that together in a way that
you move that forward and what I've
found in just in a nutshell
as a few things
um in one long sentence for me
um I want an idea meritocracy which
means the best idea to work went out I
want meaningful work and meaningful
relationships
I think that makes people rewarded
and and it's most valuable when you're
in a mission together and you're
um
challenging each other and so on but
you're in it together that's a very
powerful force and I want to do that
through radical truthfulness
don't let any barrier stand in the way
of getting at that truthfulness and
radical transparency so anyway the
sentence is Meaningful work and
meaningful relationships through radical
truthfulness and radical transparency I
have a number of sports coaches who call
me
related to the principles I won't go
down their names but they said it's the
same you know to deal with those
strengths and weaknesses and have that
relationship but I think I think that's
most rewarding and I think it's most uh
it's key to success